hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition its
round eight and its Magnus Carlsen with
the white pieces against Nikita with
YouGov and it's well it's quite the game
and I will need your help with this one
because something very well very
mysterious happens but we're gonna get
to that yeah so without further ado
let's check out the game
Magnus opens with E for sorry about that
and we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on
the board with a six more fees defense
and the bishop to a four Knight to f6
we have castles Bishop to e7 and d3
going for the closed set up we have b5
Buster back to B 3 and B 6 so these are
our old fairly standard rule opus moves
and Bishop to b2 so rare move but across
and obviously decided to go go with it
for this game we have castles by Nikita
and h3 now now with h6
rook to e1 and rook to e8 we have a
three and now worship the f8 a pretty
standard move everything the e-file for
the for the black rook we have Knight to
c3 and now this position has been read
before in both cases by Nichol serene
and in one of those games he had the
black pieces against the little echo he
played Knight to a5 and the lake was
able to win that game and in the other
game it's serene who had the white
pieces he played against a German
Grandmaster Dennis Wagner who played
nice to e7 that game ended in a draw so
these are the two known moves in the
position however here we have looked to
be 8 by Nikita and it is a new move so
as of move 12 we have a completely new
game and ok Magnus continues with Bishop
to a2 if Knight a5 ever comes it will
not come with with an attack on the
bishop and it's just a useful move in
the future you might want to develop the
rooks um we're bringing the Vajra back
to be one maybe place c3 if if needed so
nice the e7 preparing to remain over the
Knight to g6 and Magnus goes in Knight
to the H for not allowing ig6 do to do
to the pin from the disappear so you can
never play that so here Nikita pushes
the knight back we have
Knight to f3 and only now Knight to g6
and here Nikita might be looking into
some g4 ideas so Magnus goes tonight
back to h2 now grabs hold of the g4
square and c6 taking away the d5 square
from Carlson's night we have Knight to
e2 now preparing to bring the knight
over to g3 from g3 the knight can come
to f5 or even the h5 which could be very
useful in the future and now that cost
and allowed that no he's not fighting
for the d5 square anymore d5 and ok
tonight the g3 the Capra's on e4 we have
d Capra's on e4 okay the Queen trade is
not on the board because of the bishop
on D - and now rugby 7 the rook will be
now very helpful now in defense of the
seventh rank and now Queen to f3
saying that ok if you want to capture my
brush upon D - I'm gonna grab your
knight on f6 so of course I Nikita not
interested he goes in Knight to f4 and
it's an excellent square for the knight
with the e and the Jeep on controlling
it here rook 8 B 1 by Magnus putting a
look in front of the Queen so now there
are threats of Bishop captures on f4 for
example opening up a discovery rook the
d7 another good thing for playing rook
to b7 now you can well create a Queen
rook battery along the D file push up
the e3 offering the trade and now rook
captures on d1 with rook captures and
now Queen moves to e7 and here
Magnus goes and Knight to g4 it couldn't
be well it can only be helpful to play
before you don't want to you don't want
to allow black to play c5 if you allow
c5 then you kind of have to deal with it
because if you allow c4 then your life
squared Bishop is completely out of the
game but Magnus says there's there's
time for that he goes in Knight to g4
now puts pressure on the night and on
the h6 pawn and here again B to go
should go for c5 with the idea of
pushing c4 but he instead he goes for
Knight captures on g4 we have h capture
Sanji for and now truth the d8 he wants
the trade of the other look as well
however Magnus declines rook back
II won and now finally c5 and now if c-4
comes is gonna be a very dangerous
position with the light square Bishop
pretty much out of the game yes you can
bring it to be one and push c3 but still
where where is the bishop gonna go I
mean it's it's gonna be a very bad
Bishop so here first Magnus goes in
Knight to f5 attacks the Queen and video
should either move the Queen or capture
ya if you capture it's it's a very
tricky line G captures on f5 and now h5
very interesting preparing g4 so here
you basically force captures captures
and now Queen captures on h5 however now
you get c4 and now the light square
bishop is out of the game so it's not
really that big of a deal that you've
given up on pawn rook is coming to d6 to
h6 and it's gonna be a very nice
attacking piece against the white king
and it's I mean this Bishop here is just
a monster one point the kicker out of
the game is well worth it so instead the
Queen to see seven was played by B to go
and now Magnus has time before c4 his
plate he pushes g3 kicks away the night
we have knight c6 and now comes queen to
h1 by Magnus putting pressure on the h6
pawn and here is a where the the magic
sort of happens not here the the best
defense for black is nights the d4 but
it requires too much calculation and the
V to go was already very long long time
but even if you have a lot of time it I
would say it's pretty impossible to
calculate all of this because the line
goes nice the d4 now you block the block
the bishop also threatened to exchange
Knights Knight captures on h6 with Czech
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Knight to f3 with Czech forking the rook
King to f1 and now not capturing the
rook it's that work isn't going anywhere
since your Luke is regarding the d1
square first Bishop captures on g4 and
this is the problem with this variation
Bishop captures on g5 by Magnus Queen to
d6 now offering to trade Queens and now
Bishop f6 threatening mate and this is
the problem
[Music]
how do you save this with black now even
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this sneaky move while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding the only move that saves
black and it kind of brings black into a
well a small advantage and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to h3 check now the point is
the King has nowhere to go if you go
here then again you allow an ID for
check and you start hunting the white
king so you have to capture it and then
Queen captures and if six comes and here
black will be better especially if you
manage to lock down the light square
Bishop out of the game but you have to
find all of this from this position
after collison place a queen to h1 to
play to even play such a move because if
if this doesn't work and you give up the
h6 pawn well it's safe to say that that
you're just lost so here instead we have
f6 by which you go now clearing the the
seventh rank for the Queen to enter the
game and also strengthening the pawns
here but there's a problem so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the move Magnus plate while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it's obviously it's obviously a
spectacular move as after this move we
do go to resign the game so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations and for those who want
to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to d5 so a forum all the
time video go should have played c5 and
tried to get c4 in he didn't now the
bishop occupies the beautiful d5 square
and it was in this position I move 30
that Nikki tubby Tuke of resigned the
game and Magnus grabs his first victory
in the tata steel 2020 edition why did
he resign well that's not easy to answer
there is no clear reason why he resigned
because obviously there are still much
much to play he was a very long time I
think he was a little bit above 10
minutes and he said I believe he said in
an interview after that he felt very
tired which is well ok you feel tired I
don't know if that's a reason to resign
the game as even with
well okay let's let's try some moves
it's hard to play a move with black okay
your knight can't move your bishop
cannot move really because the knight
would hang the rook doesn't really have
a good square you don't really have
anything to do with the bishop so what
could you play okay let's see Queen d7
defend the knight prepare Bishop to b7
so how could this game continue b4 is
one of the main options for white always
our point being that you will either
grab a passed pawn here with characters
here as the knight is pinned or you will
capture and then finally Bishop to b6
comes and you start the harassing the
rook rook to e8 and now you capture back
so now Bishop to b7 let's say rook to d1
threatening all sorts of discoveries
Bishop captures it captures attacks the
knight Knight the d4 and now you grab
the pawn Knight captures on h6 Bishop
captures Queen captures and you get this
position where you cannot eliminate this
pawn due to check picking up the rook so
again it's it is winning for white but
it's it's hard to I don't know I would
say it's it's pretty hard to resign from
that position and this is with absolute
best play and there are there are some
other options instead of Queen to d7 you
could go Queen to h7 guard guard dh6
pawn again you have this option of b4
where okay black doesn't have to capture
if you do then again Bishop to b6 is an
option or you could go king 288 on pin
so now the knight can defend it that's
also an option but then you get a bishop
captures Bishop characters and just
Bishop characters here so winning this
point still keeping all the pressure
it's not gonna be easy for black to
unwind here but I sorry about that it
seems like there's just a lot a lot to
go by and okay maybe it's just because
he started and he's playing Carlsen but
I don't know seems like I mean okay I've
seen players resign in in in you know
not even better positions than this for
example if someone had a crampy position
against Karpov they would resign as the
I mean you're playing against Karpov but
still it's just a little bit weird so I
I didn't mmm
I don't know what's wrong with me I'm
gonna have to go back to my little sips
of water but if any of you caught the
live coverage if any of you caught the
interview I I didn't see the interview I
only caught some comments about the
interview so if you know anything more
about what happened here do share in the
comments so we can all increase our
knowledge about this encounter but yeah
all in all Magnus grabs his first
victory in the Tata Steel 2020 masters
edition and tomorrow he faces holidays a
Fallujah with the black pieces so it's
gonna be it's gonna be awesome
so now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Robert
Fischer and the Nicole Arbour for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata Steel masters edition there are a
few more games we're gonna cover from
around 8:00 as around 8 is pretty crazy
continuing the coverage of the Women's
World Chess Championship checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and so on so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent race to our Sunday